This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一档 IHeart 播客。绝对真人。“回顾往事”播客。从 1979 年开始，这对我和我来说都是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是 Sam J.，我是 Alex English。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的伙伴以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听“回顾往事”。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听 Learn the Hardway，我是你们最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都绝对无法安全展开的坦诚对话，而你正与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士一起交流。有多少男人背负着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力，就必须这样做。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Learn the Hardway。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lusbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。网络侦探大军经过一番调查，揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样遭遇的男人。格雷格·拉斯比安（Greg Lusbian）。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everyone, welcome back to a new episode of the show. Thank you for tuning in.
我的脑子彻底炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是 Love Trapped。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。哈喽，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，在这里我们探讨二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好，欢迎回到节目的新一期。谢谢你们的收听。
Thanks for joining us today as we talk about another interesting topic. Like I say, every week, every topic I kind of like to cover is one that I personally feel a lot of feelings, feel a lot of truth to, or is something that as a person in their 20s I have been through, I've been experiencing, or, discussing with friends, with family, with people around me, this is obviously no different. And it's also a really big and crucial one and one that has a lot of ties to our mental health, not just our overall psychological perspectives and well-being. I think a lot of the times when people hear like psychology, they often think mental illness. I try and stay away from that because I really want to be able to expand people's knowledge of this topic and this discipline and understand that it covers a lot more
感谢大家今天加入我们，一起探讨另一个有趣的话题。就像我每周所说的那样，我挑选并报道的每一个话题，都是那种我个人感触良多、深以为然的话题，或者作为一个正处于二十多岁的人，我曾经历过、正在经历，或是经常与朋友、家人以及身边的人讨论的话题，今天这个话题显然也不例外。而且它也是一个非常重大、至关重要的话题，它与我们的心理健康有着千丝万缕的联系，而不仅仅关乎我们的整体心理视角和幸福感。我想很多时候，当人们听到“心理学”这个词时，往往会联想到精神疾病。我尽量避免这种局限，因为我真的希望能够拓展人们对这个话题和这门学科的认知，让他们明白它涵盖的内容要广泛得多，
than just some kind of illness that's going on or some kind of mental unwellness. But this week I really wanted to talk about something that might be related to some kind of mental distress or discomfort that you're feeling, especially in our 20s. So this week we're talking about identity crises, an identity crisis. that might come along in our 20s later on or earlier. It might be something that you're going through. And I want to really approach it from a growth mindset, from a growing perspective rather than one that is negative.
不仅仅是某种正在发生的疾病或某种心理不适。但本周，我真的很想聊聊一些可能与你感受到的某种心理困扰或不适相关的事情，特别是在我们二十多岁的时候。所以本周我们来聊聊身份危机，也就是可能在我们二十多岁后期或早期悄然降临的身份危机。这可能是你正在经历的事情。我希望以一种成长的心态、用发展的视角来看待它，而不是用消极的眼光。
There are a lot of studies that I did, a lot of studies that I looked at when I was researching this, all of them saying the same thing. This kind of event is kind of impossible. to avoid and something that all of us have to go through in our early adulthood, which is probably for most of you right now. Maybe you're finding yourself experiencing an identity crisis where you really are looking deeply at yourself or, you know, kind of assessing your life and your surroundings and not really knowing who you are. It's not so much about not knowing where you're
我做过很多研究，在我进行研究时看过的许多研究，都在诉说着同一件事。这种类型的事件几乎是无法避免的，也是我们所有人步入成年初期都必须经历的一个过程，对于你们中的大多数人来说，现在可能正处于这个阶段。也许你发现自己正在经历一场身份危机，你开始真正深刻地审视自我，或者，你知道的，开始评估你的生活和周围环境，却不太清楚自己究竟是谁。这其实并不是关于不知道你正要
going or not knowing what the future holds. I do have some episodes on that, but more really not knowing who you are at your core and how that kind of bleeds into the rest of our life. So I'm really, really keen for today's episode. Like I said, a lot of these, a lot of this content is things that I personally am finding interesting at the moment. This is no different. And when I was looking into it, I found so many interesting things. I was saying to my housemate, he was asking me, oh, you know, like, what episode are you doing this week? And I was like, oh, I'm going to do an episode on identity crisis and he was like, oh, do you think that's what you're going through right now? And I was like, no. And the reason why I don't think that is because I did all this
去往何方，或者不知道未来会怎样。我有一些关于这方面的单集节目，但它更多的是关于真的不清楚自己核心深处究竟是谁，以及这种状态是如何渗透到我们生活的方方面面中的。所以我对今天的节目真的非常非常期待。就像我说的，很多这样的内容都是我个人目前觉得很有趣的事情。这一次也不例外。当我深入研究时，我发现了如此多有趣的事情。我跟我室友聊天的时候，他问我，哦，你知道的，你这周要做哪一期节目？然后我说，哦，我要做一期关于身份危机的节目，接着他说，哦，你觉得这就是你目前正在经历的事情吗？我说，不是。我之所以不这么认为，是因为我做了所有这些
research. And it's made me better able to identify, you know, what I'm feeling. But if you are going through some kind of massive or major change or shift in your life and you don't really know where you stand, you don't really have a clear sense of identity, then this episode is for you. First, I just want to kind of define what we're talking about today. So an identity crisis, it's a developmental event, and it involves a person, maybe yourself, questioning their sense of self and their place in the world. And the concept, it originates in the work of this developmental psychologist, if you are a psychology student.
研究。这让我能够更好地识别，你知道的，我现在的感受。但如果你正在经历某种巨大的、重大的生活改变或转变，并且你真的不知道自己身处何地、立场何在，对自我没有清晰的身份认知，那么这一期节目就是为你准备的。首先，我想先定义一下我们今天要讨论的内容。所以，身份危机，它是一个发展心理学事件，涉及一个人（也许就是你自己）对自我感知以及自己在世界中的位置产生质疑。这个概念源于这位发展心理学家的著作，如果你是一名心理学学生，
I hope you recognize the name. His name is Eric Erickson. I know, cute name. Eric Erickson. He was a psychoanalyst in the 1900s. And he believed that the formation of identity was one of the most important conflicts that people face. It's a challenge. It's a developmental event that we have to overcome in order to kind of recognize our true self.
我希望你能认出这个名字。他的名字叫埃里克·埃里克森（Eric Erickson）。我知道，名字挺可爱的。埃里克·埃里克森。他是20世纪的一位精神分析学家。他认为，身份的形成是人们面临的最重要的冲突之一。这是一个挑战，是我们为了认清真正的自我而必须克服的一个发展事件。
And according to Erickson, an identity crisis is a time of really intensive analysis and self-discovery and exploration of different ways of perceiving and looking at ourselves. and he noted that developing a sense of identity is really important during our early adulthood, beginning obviously in our teenage years, but also our early and late 20s. And our identity, it's not a stagnant thing that we create, you know, over a day and we're loyal to for the rest of our lives. Who we were five years ago is not who we are now, I would hope so. And it's highly likely that your identity and your sense is. of self-concept is going to be hugely different in a lot of major ways, five years from now,
根据埃里克森的观点，身份危机是一个进行深度分析、自我发现以及探索感知和看待自我之不同方式的时期。并且他指出，在成年初期，建立身份感是非常重要的，这一过程显然始于我们的青少年时期，但也延续到我们二十多岁的早年和晚年。我们的身份并非一成不变，不是说你在某一天创造了它，然后余生都对它忠心耿耿。五年前的我们和现在的我们绝非同一个人，我希望如此。并且，五年后的你，
let alone 10 or 20. And that is such an incredible thing. It's an incredible blessing that we can develop and be different people across our lives and that our brains and our minds and our overall self-concept allows us to do this and allows us to develop based on what's going on our lives. So today we're going to break down this discussion of identity crisis into four sections. So we're going to talk about identity first. That seems like a pretty good building block. What is identity? We all seem to have one. But what are its contents? What is it specifically? You know, I don't think we can necessarily point to a collection of items or our jobs or our friends and families and say, well, this is me, summed up, this is who I am. It's something a lot deeper and
更不用说十年或二十年后，你的身份和自我概念极有可能会在许多重大方面发生巨大变化。这真是一件了不起的事情。我们能够在漫长的一生中不断成长、成为不同的人，我们的头脑、思维以及整体自我概念允许我们做到这一点，并能根据我们生活中的发生的事情不断发展，这真是一个巨大的恩赐。因此，今天我们将把关于身份危机的讨论分为四个部分。首先，我们来谈谈身份。这似乎是一个相当不错的基石。什么是身份？我们似乎都有一个身份。但它的内容是什么？它具体指的是什么？你知道的，我认为我们不一定能指出某项具体的事物、我们的工作、我们的朋友和家人，然后说，看，这就是我，这就是我的全部，这就是我是谁。它其实深邃得多，
nuanced and quite frankly, sometimes intangible. Then we're going to discuss why does a crisis of identity occur and what does it symbolize internally for our psychology and what does it feel like mentally, socially, emotionally and importantly for the last kind of section of the podcast, we're going to talk about what comes after. How do we push through this hard and sometimes very dark period where we're questioning ourselves and our identity and emerge at the other end, hopefully better and brighter and representing our true selves? Okay, so let's jump straight in.
充满了细微差别，坦白说，有时甚至有些难以言喻。然后，我们将探讨为什么会发生身份危机，它在我们的心理层面内部象征着什么，在精神、社交、情感上究竟是什么感觉，而最重要的是，在播客的最后一部分，我们将探讨接下来会发生什么。我们如何度过这段艰难的、有时非常黑暗的时期——在这期间我们质疑自己和自己的身份——并在另一端脱颖而出，希望变得更好、更耀眼，展现出真实的自我？好吧，那我们就直接切入正题吧。
We're going to talk about identity. What is identity? A huge, massive question I know to kind of pose to us. But the idea and conception of identity is such an incredible. complex topic. Identity is really concerned with this question of who am I and what does it mean to be me? And that might seem like a pretty easy answer for some, but for others it can be a lot more difficult. How we view ourselves as a huge combination of so many factors. And because our identity is constantly shifting, particularly in young adulthood, one element of our identity.
我们来聊聊身份。什么是身份？我知道这是一个抛给我们的宏大得无以复加的问题。但是关于身份的想法和概念，是一个极其复杂的课题。身份真正关乎的是这样一个问题：我是谁？作为“我”意味着什么？对某些人来说，这似乎是一个相当简单的答案，但对其他人而言，它可能要困难得多。我们如何看待自己，是众多因素高度结合的产物。而且由于我们的身份在不断变化，尤其是在年轻的成年阶段，我们身份中的某个元素
is likely to be more prominent at any given time and where we kind of see ourselves in relation to others and how we view ourselves is likely to be undergoing a lot of major changes during this decade. So let's start by breaking this down into some kind of sizable categories. And as we go through these, I really want you to take some time to contemplate exactly what these categories mean for you, especially if you're listening to. this episode today because you might be experiencing an identity crisis. So identity, it includes quite a few elements. Firstly, our personal qualities that we have little to no control over. So our family, our cultural backgrounds, skin color, sexuality, where we were born, you know,
在任何特定时间都可能更加突出，并且我们如何看待自己与他人的关系，以及我们如何看待自己，在这十年中很可能会经历许多重大变化。因此，让我们首先把这个概念拆解成一些易于消化的类别。在我们过这些类别时，我真的希望你能花点时间仔细琢磨，这些类别对你而言究竟意味着什么，特别是如果你今天收听这期节目是因为你可能正在经历身份危机的话。所以，身份包含了相当多的元素。首先，是我们几乎无法控制的个人品质。比如我们的家庭、文化背景、肤色、性取向、我们出生的地方，你知道的，
if someone is particularly nationalistic and that's important for their identity, they may place a really great emphasis on their identity as a member of a certain country. For example, you know, they're Australian, they like a barbecue, they're like the beach and kind of the assumptions that comes along with that. Identity also relates to our basic values. And these dictate the choices that we make in our relationships, in our career, in our daily lives, towards really important things like our health, like where we live. And all of these choices, they reflect who we are and what we value. And our values, and our values, They might include things like honesty or authenticity, dependability, gratitude,
如果一个人有强烈的民族主义倾向，而这对他的身份认同至关重要，他可能会把作为某个国家成员的身份看得极重。例如，你知道的，他们是澳大利亚人，他们喜欢烧烤，喜欢海滩，以及伴随这些而来的各种理所当然的看法。身份还与我们的基本价值观息息相关。这些价值观决定了我们在人际关系、职业生涯、日常生活中所做的选择，以及诸如健康、居住地等真正重要的事情。所有这些选择，都反映了我们是谁以及我们珍视什么。而我们的价值观，
trustworthiness, the list goes on and on. And I think a really great exercise to do when you're feeling somewhat unstable in your self-perception and what you stand for is to take a few minutes. Pause this podcast. I'm not going anywhere, but take a few minutes and think about your five most important values, whatever they may be. What are the five values that truly represent who you are and be honest with yourself about how you might embody these values and what you can do to reinforce this value system within yourself?
可能包括诚实、真实、可靠、感恩、值得信赖等品质，这个清单可以一直列下去。我认为，当你在自我认知以及自己的立场上感到有些动摇时，一个非常棒的练习就是花几分钟时间。暂停这个播客。我哪儿也不会去，但请花几分钟时间想一想对你而言最重要的五个价值观，无论它们是什么。真正代表你是谁的五个价值观是什么？并对自己保持诚实：你将如何体现这些价值观，以及你可以做些什么来强化内心的这个价值体系？
If you're someone who doesn't see, I don't know, trustworthiness as particularly important, maybe that's a bad example. Maybe like a value for you is freedom. But if you're someone who's happy to kind of live within constraints and it's happy to be kind of a follower, rather than a leader. Be really honest with yourself about whether that's a value. I want you to take time to identify five, five of the most important. And these values, they inform our moral character as well, which guide us through this world and any kind of crosswords we may come across. And they also, as is stated in this episode, really important for our identity. They are those
如果你是一个觉得，我不知道，信任并不是特别重要的人，也许这是一个不恰当的例子。也许对你来说，价值观是自由。但如果你是一个乐于活在各种约束之中，并且愿意做一个追随者而不是领导者的人。那么请对自己开诚布公，这到底是不是你的价值观。我希望你花时间找出五个，最重要的五个价值观。这些价值观同时也构成了我们的道德品质，指引我们在这个世界上前行，并引导我们跨越可能遇到的任何十字路口。正如本集节目中所阐述的，它们对我们的身份认同至关重要。它们是我们赖以建立大量自我概念的
deep, fundamental building blocks on which we build a lot of our self-concept. Our identity, it also relates to our social roles which we hold or we might inhabit. For example, when I might look at myself or someone might ask me, who are you? I might say, you know, I'm a podcast host. I'm an employee. I'm a friend. I'm a sister. I'm a daughter. I'm a woman. And in each of these roles, I might act differently or make different decisions based on the context. But together, they really help discern who I am and what I represent and the choices I inevitably make. Sometimes these unique identities which are associated with our social roles can come into conflict. For example, you might see yourself as a student, but also as a traveler or an adventurer as a daughter, a son, a symboling, a family
深层、基础的积木。我们的身份，还与我们所持有或占据的社会角色有关。例如，当我审视自己，或者有人问我“你是谁”时，我可能会说，你知道的，我是一个播客主持人。我是一名雇员。我是朋友。我是姐姐。我是女儿。我是女人。在每一个这些角色中，我可能会根据不同的语境做出不同的行为或抉择。但综合起来，它们确实有助于辨别我是谁、我代表什么，以及我不可避免地做出的选择。有时，这些与我们的社会角色相关的独特身份可能会产生冲突。例如，你可能认为自己是一名学生，但同时也是一名旅行者或冒险家、一个女儿、一个儿子、一个兄弟姐妹、一个家庭
member. And maybe your time commitments with school interrupt your ability to fully commit to those other social roles and identities that you find important in which case some dissonance and potentially an identity crisis may arise when two of our social roles come into conflict with each other. And very similar, but slightly different to this idea of social role, is our identity within a social group. So for example, your religious identity, or if you're part of a sports team or a large community base, which shares a common interest in similar patterns of behaviours or even appearances. This is a really weird example, but I often like to think of like furries as an example of this. Like, that is a community and that is a big part of someone's social identity. You know,
成员。也许你在学业上的时间承诺，打乱了你全心投入其他你认为重要的社会角色和身份的能力。在这种情况下，当我们的两个社会角色彼此冲突时，就会产生一些认知失调，并可能引发身份危机。与这种社会角色的概念非常相似、但又略有不同的是我们在社交群体中的身份。例如，你的宗教身份，或者如果你是一个运动队的成员，亦或是一个有着共同兴趣、相似行为模式甚至外表的庞大社区的成员。这是一个非常奇怪的例子，但我经常喜欢把“福瑞控”（furries）作为这方面的例子。你看，这是一个社群，这也是某人社交身份中很大的一部分。你知道的，
they have similar hobbies and similar interests or if you're part of like a big fan base for something, that might be really, really important for your identity because you have this shared sense of purpose and a shared sense of doing and of being. This links with our next kind of element or facet of identity. And this is the one that I think is probably the most important, maybe just as important as our value system. Our identity is formed by our passions, by our mission and our hobbies. What do we really care about?
他们有相似的爱好和兴趣，或者如果你是某个庞大粉丝群体的一员，这对于你的身份认同可能非常非常重要，因为你们有这种共享的目标感、共同的行动方式和生存状态。这与我们的下一个身份元素或切面息息相关。而这一个，我认为可能是最重要的，也许和我们的价值体系同样重要。我们的身份是由我们的热情、使命和爱好所塑造的。我们真正关心的是什么？
what is our purpose in life? And if you're going through an identity crisis, that question is going to be hard to answer. It's hard to answer at any time. That is a huge extraditional question. Like, what is our purpose in life? But maybe it's better to scale that back to what do I love doing? What is my mission? For example, you know, you might believe that your mission on this earth is to protect nature is to protect the earth. Maybe it's to help others make beautiful things, create, nurture or make money and build a fortune. This kind of assumption about what we're here for forms a really core part of your identity. And it's totally okay if you don't know what that is right now. I was talking to my friend Gia the other day and she was like, I just know that one day I'm
我们在生活中的目标是什么？如果你正在经历身份危机，这个问题将很难回答。在任何时候回答这个问题都不容易。这是一个极其宏大的问题。比如，我们在生活中的目的是什么？但也许缩小范围会更好：我热爱做什么？我的使命是什么？例如，你知道的，你可能会认为你在地球上的使命是保护自然、保护地球。也许是帮助他人创造美丽的事物、去创造、去培育，或者是赚钱并建立财富。这种关于我们为何来到这里的假设，构成了你身份的核心部分。如果你现在还不知道那是什么，完全没有关系。前几天我和我的朋友吉亚（Gia）聊天，她说，我只知道总有一天我会
going to come across something and realize this is for me. And I really do believe that's going to happen for her. There's so many opportunities and changes in our lives where we really get to kind of get to the core of what we believe in, but also what we think our mission here is. And it's also made up of smaller things, specifically what we love, what kind of stokes the fire in your belly. You know, when you're meeting someone new, you might define yourself first by your hobbies, you know, that you play football or you crochet or you run marathons or you meditate or you paint, I don't know, whatever you're into, those elements of what you love doing and what you fill your free time with are just as crucial as some of those bigger picture things like your values.
遇到某样东西，然后意识到这就是为我而生。我真的相信这会发生在她身上。我们的生活中有着如此多的机遇和变化，让我们能够真正触及我们所信仰的核心，以及我们认为自己来这里的使命所在。它也由一些更小的事情组成，具体来说，就是我们热爱什么、是什么在点燃你内心的火焰。你知道的，当你结识新朋友时，你可能首先会通过你的爱好来定义自己，你知道的，你踢足球、织毛衣、跑马拉松、冥想还是画画，我不知道，无论你对什么感兴趣，这些关于你热爱做什么以及你如何填补空闲时间的元素，与那些诸如价值观之类的大局观事物同样至关重要。
And these elements are just as crucial, although they may not immediately come to mind. All of these small things build up to create us. They create our identity because it is a multi-layered construct. It's not just one thing. And although the big things might come first, they're not the most important. And as we dive deeper, we are able to see what is truly at the core of ourselves, not just our social role, not just the family or the life that we were born into. And I think something that I've noticed and something that psychology really backs up is
这些元素同样至关重要，尽管它们可能不会立刻浮现在脑海中。所有这些微小的事情累积起来造就了我们。它们创造了我们的身份，因为这是一个多层次的结构。它不仅仅是一件单一的事情。尽管宏大的事物可能会首先出现，但它们并非最重要的。当我们深入探索时，我们能够看到自己内心真正核心的东西，而不仅仅是我们的社会角色、不仅仅是我们出生的家庭或生活。而且我认为我注意到的一件事，以及心理学真正支持的一件事是，
you can tell a lot about someone by their response to a question like, who are you? If I were to ask you this question right now, what would you say? Would you define yourself by your ethnicity or your nationality, maybe by your values and your beliefs, your social roles, maybe by your mission, your hobbies, what you love or who you love? And often when our identity is defined by external factors rather than those deep core beliefs, But things like our achievements, our political identity, our social roles, our performative behaviours, or duty, that's when we can find ourselves quite detached from our true selves and who we are at our core, our belief systems, our passion and our mission. And this brings me to possibly my favourite element of identity, which is the existence of our true selves.
你可以从一个人对诸如“你是谁”之类问题的回答中看出很多关于他的一切。如果我现在问你这个问题，你会怎么说？你会用你的种族或国籍来定义自己，也许是用你的价值观和信仰、你的社会角色，也许是用你的使命、你的爱好、你所热爱的事物或你所爱的人？通常，当我们的身份是由外部因素而不是那些深层的核心信仰所定义时，
when we look at some of those factors that create our identity, like I kind of mentioned before, some of them seem a lot more peripheral and less important than others. And this is where the distinction between our true self and our false or peripheral self kind of comes into this equation of identity. So our true self, this refers to a sense of self based on authentic experience. and the feeling of being truly present and alive and honest about who you are. So elements that make up our true selves include our deep inner values, our mission, our purpose, the connections we have with those that we love, maybe our religious beliefs, our goals,
比如我们的成就、我们的政治身份、我们的社会角色、我们的表演性行为或责任感，这正是我们发现自己与真实的自我以及核心的自我——我们的信念系统、激情和使命——严重脱节的时候。这就把我带到了我可能最喜欢的身份元素，那就是真实自我的存在。当我们审视那些创造我们身份的因素时，正如我之前提到的，其中一些看起来比另一些更加边缘且不那么重要。这就是真实自我与虚假或边缘自我之间的区别进入身份方程式的地方。因此，我们的真实自我，指的是基于真实体验的自我感，
and our self-concept, how we feel about ourselves, whether we feel good about ourselves, whether we see ourselves in a positive life. And our false self, it's kind of a different. offensive facade and behind this facade you can feel really empty. It's based on behaviors and an identity that's learnt and controlled rather than spontaneous and authentic and genuine. And it's made up of elements and factors of identity that I would say are pretty superficial and inconsistent or unstable like how we wish others to receive us. Maybe beauty and appearance and status. When we're able to identify our true self and exhibit it throughout what we do in every moment
以及那种真正感到当下存在、充满活力、对真实的自己诚实的感受。构成我们真实自我的元素包括我们深层的内在价值观、使命、目标、我们与所爱之人的联系、也许还有我们的宗教信仰、我们的目标，以及我们的自我概念——我们对自己的感受，我们是否对自己感觉良好，我们是否以积极的眼光看待自己。而我们的虚假自我，则有点像是一个不同的进攻性外表，而在这个外表背后，你会感到极度的空虚。它基于一种被学习和控制的行为与身份，而不是自发的、真实的和真诚的。它由身份中那些可以说是相当表面、不一致或不稳定的元素和因素组成，比如我们希望别人如何接纳我们。也许是美貌、外表和地位。当我们能够识别出真实的自我，并在每一刻的所作所为中展现它，
and embody our kind of pure intentions and our desires and our missions, we're likely to be a lot happier and fulfilled because we're in pursuit of becoming our best selves and making decisions with our core values at hand. We know what's important to us. But more importantly, who we are when all the facades and trinkets and material things are stripped away becomes more apparent and becomes more crucial to how we live our daily lives. But let's get to this next topic. What happens when that type of self, our true self, is confusing and unstable and really
体现我们纯粹的意图、愿望和使命时，我们很可能会更加快乐和充实，因为我们在追求成为最好的自己，并且在做决策时手握核心价值观。我们知道什么对我们来说是重要的。但更重要的是，当所有的外表、小饰品和物质东西被剥离后，我们究竟是谁变得更加清晰，并且对我们如何过好日常生活变得至关重要。但让我们进入下一个话题。当那种类型的自我——我们的真实自我——变得令人困惑、不稳定，并且在当时很难辨认时，会发生什么呢？这就把我们带到了今天讨论的中心，那就是经历身份危机。因此，身份危机，被定义为一个充满不确定性和困惑的时期，在这个时期里，
difficult to identify in the moment? That brings us to kind of the center of our discussion today, which is the experience of having an identity crisis. So an identity crisis, it's defined as a period of uncertainty and confusion in which which a person may be yourself at the moment, your sense of identity becomes insecure, typically due to some kind of unexpected change in your role in society, in your aims, in your lifestyle. And huge transitions in our 20s put our identity into question in a way that we often don't have to question it in other periods of our life. If we think about our 20s, it's defined by
你当下的身份感变得不再安全，通常是由于你在社会角色、目标、生活方式上发生了某种意料之外的变化。我们二十多岁时的巨大转变使我们的身份受到质疑，这种质疑方式在我们生命的其他时期往往是不需要的。如果我们回想一下我们的二十多岁，它是由巨大的变化所定义的。它是由成长所定义的。我们必须努力驾驭过去那个自己、现在的自己以及未来最终想成为的自己之间那个奇怪的空间。而且有太多的事情可以引发或催化这种类型的、且确实是迅速的转变和我们自我身份的转变。让我们想几个例子。比如离开学校、毕业。对于二十出头的人来说，这是一段非常重大的经历。
massive change. It's defined by growing up. And we have to try and navigate that weird space between who we used to be, who we are now, and who we ultimately want to be in the future. And so many things can trigger or catalyze this type of rapid, and really is a rapid transition and shift in our self-identity. Let's think about a few. Like leaving school, graduating. That's something that is a really huge experience for people in their early 20s.
搬去不同的国家、不同的州。失去父母、朋友、家庭成员，或是遭遇悲剧、经历分手。我们稍后会更多地谈到这一点。疾病和受伤，你知道的，随着我们年龄的增长，当我们步入二十多岁时，各种状况就会出现。我们不再年轻了。你知道的，你可能会患上慢性病。你可能会发现自己受伤了。你可能会发现自己身体抱恙。这确实是那种自我发现以及随之而来的身份危机的真正催化剂。还有其他一些更微妙的事情，也可能成为我们生活中重大的创伤和重大的转变，比如失去朋友、被解雇、搬出原生家庭。
Moving countries, moving states. a loss of a parent, of a friend, of a family member, or a tragedy, a breakup. We're going to talk about that a little bit more. Illness and injury, you know, things come up as we age, as we enter into our 20s. We're not young anymore. You know, you might be developing chronic illnesses. You might find yourself being injured. You might find yourself being unwell. And that's a real kind of catalyst for that kind of self-discovery and the identity crisis that might come with it. And there are other just more subtle things that can be a significant trauma and a significant shift in our lives, like losing friends, getting fired, moving out of home.
基本上，触发这种经历的最大诱因就是变化，在这种变化中，我们被迫在不确定性的环境中做出决定，并在一个令人不舒服的领域中前行，在这个领域里，我们可能更难记起自己的价值观、使命以及我们热爱的事物——那些让我们真正成为我们的东西。让我们以分手的例子来解释这一点，因为我认为这可能会引起许多人的共鸣，我们中的许多人在某个时刻都曾陷入爱河，而现在发现自己，嗯，不再恋爱了，或者至少不再和同一个人恋爱了。正如我之前提到的，我们的身份与我们的社会角色以及我们与他人的关系紧密相连，随之而来的是，我们的价值观、信仰和目标
Basically, the biggest trigger for this experience is change in which we're forced to make decisions from a place of uncertainty and in kind of an uncomfortable terrain where we might find it harder to remember our values and our mission and the things we love, what makes us really us. Let's use that breakup example for this because I think it might resonate with a lot of those, a lot of us who have been in love at some point and now find ourselves, you know, well, not in love or at least not in love with the same person. Like I mentioned before, our identities, they become very tied up in our social. roles and our relationships to others and with that our values, our beliefs and our goals
也可能会与这个人保持一致。虽然在恋爱关系中，我相信我们许多人都有过这种经历，恋爱关系是人们之间脆弱而亲密的结合。你知道的，你选择了某人，并选择花大量时间与他们相处、了解他们。我们可能开始不仅将自己视为一个独立的个体，而且视为一个伴侣、一个照顾者、一个爱人，我们的爱好也会被他们塑造。我们一起做什么，我们如何度过时间。随之而来的是，我们可能还会看到我们的价值观和信仰发生改变。但当这一切结束时，我们需要恢复我们身份中那些被忽视的旧部分，或者我们需要塑造新的部分，这就会导致一种危机感，有时甚至无法
might become aligned to this other person as well. And whilst in a relationship, I'm sure many of us have had this experience, like a relationship is a really vulnerable and intimate union of people. You know, you've chosen someone and you've chosen to spend a lot of time with them and get to know them. And we might begin to see ourselves not just as an individual, but as a partner, as a caregiver, as our lover, and our hobbies become molded by them. What we do together, how we spend our time. And with that, we might also see a change in our values and beliefs. But when it's over, we have to recover all these old parts of our identity that we neglected, or we need to form new ones, and that leads to a sense of crisis and an inability to sometimes
认出自己。从大学或技校毕业时也是如此。我们曾经把自己视为学生，并用随之而来的活动和职责来定义自己。你知道的，学习、在考试中表现出色，以及有时我们的信仰体系。你知道的，我很好学。我相信努力工作。但当这种身份不再适用于我们时，我们就会进入并可能进入生活中的一个极其混乱的时期。也许你们中的许多人目前正在经历这种状态，此时此刻，我们对自己在世界上的存在感到非常不确定。我们的位置在哪里？人们对我们有什么期望？我们如何定义自己的价值？那么接下来会发生什么呢？好吧，我们可能会经历身份危机。就像我说的，
recognize ourselves. And the same can be said when we graduate from uni or from a trade. we used to see ourselves as a student and defined ourselves by what activities and duties come along with that. You know, studying, performing well on exams and our belief system at times. You know, I am studious. I believe in hard work. But when that identity is no longer available to us, we enter and can enter into a really confusing period of our lives. Maybe a lot of you are experiencing at the moment, this at the moment, whereby we're really unsure of where we exist. in the world. What's our place? What do people expect of us? And how do we define our worth? So what kind of comes next? Well, we may experience an identity crisis. Like I said, a lot of the
许多关于这种经历和事件的最初研究是由精神分析学家埃里克·埃里克森完成的，他在身份和自我概念的观点上做了很多基础工作。因此，“身份危机”这个术语是由埃里克森创造的，他在阐述这一理论时借鉴了自己生活中的经历。那么，我们先不去讨论这个理论的科学合法性或可靠性。我想大家都知道，当某些东西是轶事时，它的说服力就会稍微欠缺一点，但他确实列出了个人人格和身份心理社会发展的这八个阶段。身份危机是这个发展光谱中的一个阶段，根据他的说法，通常在我们步入成年初期时出现。在他看来，这是转变的正常部分，是生活正常的一部分。之所以会出现这种情况，
original work done into this experience and this event was done by Eric Erickson, this psychoanalyst, and he did a lot of groundwork on ideas of identity and self-concept. So the term identity crisis, it was coined by Erickson and he drew on his experiences from his own life in formulating this theory. Let's not get into the scientific legitimacy or reliability of this theory then. I think we all know that when something is anecdotal, it's a little bit less sound, but he laid out these eight phases of psychosocial development of individual personality and identity. An identity crisis is a phase in this development spectrum, and it usually occurs according to him when we enter early adulthood. In his opinion, it's a normal part of transitions, it's a normal part of life. And it occurs
是因为在成年初期，这是我们开始寻求个性化的时期，我们会深入思考除了社会角色和与他人的关系（主要是家庭）之外，我们究竟是谁。个性包含了一种独特性感，并根据你自己的倾向、愿望和使命来发展自我形象。这一阶段的每一次经历都会影响我们自我身份的发展。我所说的这个阶段是指我们正成为成年人的这个阶段。在这个时期，我们真正开始质疑，你知道的，生命的意义，我们在社会中的功能、我们的角色、我们的目的等等。通常，这种关于我们如何看待自己和个性的宏大转变，是由某种外部的重大变化引发的，正如我们之前所解释的，它迫使我们真正重新思考我们是谁。因此，当我们达到这个阶段时，心理学得出的结论以及许多研究都发现，我们将不可避免地经历一些相同的事情。
because in early adulthood, this is when we begin to seek individuality, and we deeply consider who we are beyond our social roles and our relationships to others, mainly our family. And individuality comprises a sense of uniqueness and developing a self-image according to your own inclinations and desires and mission. Every experience in this stage impacts our development of self-identity. And what I mean by this stage is this stage where we're becoming an adult. And in this period, we really begin to question, you know, the meaning of life, where we function in society, our role, our purpose, and so on. And often this grand kind of shift in how we see
比如自尊心低落、质疑自己的价值或自我价值、不觉得自己是个好人、感到非常迷茫或漫无目标，仿佛你没有方向或指南针来指引你走向正确的方向。想象一下毕业时的经历。你知道的，你过去有一个非常明确的目标。比如我正朝着毕业努力。我正朝着取得好成绩努力，然后突然之间你不再是一个学生了。所以你究竟处在什么
ourselves and our individuality is triggered by some big external change which forces us to really rethink who we are, like we explained before. So when we reach this stage, psychology kind of concludes and a lot of studies have found that we will inevitably experience some of the same things. Things like low self-esteem and questioning your value or your worth, not seeing yourself as a good person, feeling really lost or aimless, like you don't really have a direction or a compass to point you in the right direction. Think about that in kind of the experience of graduating. You know, you used to have this really clear goal. Like I'm working towards graduating. I'm working towards getting good grades and then suddenly you're not a student anymore. So where do you
位置呢？它还可能使身份危机让你在情绪上感到极度散乱，你会发现自己很难调节情绪。你可能会感到一种不断增加的不安全感，仿佛世界正在你周围改变，因为你真的不知道自己立场何在。你可能会开始质疑诸如你的价值观和信仰、你的职业道路和你的探索。并且你在寻找更多的意义、更多的理由或生活中的激情，我猜这伴随着个性的发展而产生。你知道的，你终于可以为自己做决定了，通常当生活中的重大压力和重大事件来临时，它会把很多事情纳入正确的视角。身份危机通常会非常困难。你可能会感到
kind of sit? It also, an identity crisis might make you feel really emotionally scattered and you're finding it really difficult to regulate your emotions. You feel maybe an increased sense of insecurity like the world is changing around you because you don't really know where you stand. And you might begin to question things like your values and your beliefs, your career path and your search. And you're searching for more meaning, for more reason or passion in your life, I guess that comes along with that development of individuality. You know, you get to finally make decisions for yourself and often when big life stresses and big life events come around, it puts a lot of things into perspective. And an identity crisis can often be really difficult. You might feel
非常焦虑或非常沮丧，因为你的自我概念不复存在了。现在，我们的朋友埃里克·埃里克森认为，这是生活的一个非常正常和自然的部分。我非常赞同这一点。我认为确实如此。我们所有人都必须在某个时刻到达这个阶段，我们必须审查我们旧的、继承下来的信仰体系、我们旧的身份，并为自己决定我们想成为谁。正如我所说，这可能是在某些生活重大压力之后发生的。但还有另一种由另一位临床心理学家提出的替代方案。他的名字叫詹姆斯·玛西亚（James Marcia）。我不知道他是否还在世，但詹姆斯·玛西亚仍然是他的名字。他有着与埃里克森不同的视角。他通过提出我们所有人为了最终形成身份都必须经历这四个阶段，进一步推进了身份形成的理论。
really anxious or really depressed because your sense of self-concept is no longer there. Now, our friend, Eric Erickson, he believes this is a really normal and natural part of life. And I really agree with this. I think it is. We all have to come to this stage at some point where we have to review our old inherited belief systems, our old identity and decide for ourselves who we want to be. And like I said, this might come in the wake of some major life stresses. But there's also an alternative kind of proposal by another clinical psychologist. His name was James Marcia. I don't know if he's still alive, but James Marcia is still his name. And he had this different perspective than Erickson did. And he kind of furthered the theory of identity
这四个阶段是：过早认同（foreclosure）、扩散（diffusion）、延缓（moratorium）和获得（achievement）。因此，身份过早认同，即第一阶段，指的是在没有进行探索的情况下对某个身份做出承诺。我们就是我们，我们并没有真正思考过这个问题。这就是我们的家庭抚养我们的方式。这就是我们的环境塑造我们的方式。你知道的，如果你是一个在非常保守的家庭中长大的人，你可能只是继承了一个由周围人（你知道的，由你的家庭）强加给你的身份。虽然你拥有一个身份，但它并没有真正包含你自己的元素。它并不是真正独特的。它不是个性的，而且你也没有真正思考过它。
formation by suggesting that we all have to go through these four stages of finally coming to our identity. These stages are foreclosure, diffusion, moratorium and achievement. So identity foreclosure, the first stage refers to a commitment to an identity without exploration. We are just who we are and we haven't really thought about it. This is how our family raised us. This is how our environment has kind of shaped us. You know, if you were someone who grew up in a really conservative household, you might merely inherent an identity that's been opposed on you by others around you, you know, by your family. And although you have an identity, it doesn't really contain elements of yourself. It's not really unique. It's not individual and you haven't really
你知道的，如果我们用大学或毕业的例子，如果你从三岁到二十一岁或者无论我们什么时候大学毕业，你一生都在学习，我们拥有一个从未真正接受过检验的学生身份。它是继承来的，而且感觉很正常。但当个人开始因某种原因或某种巨大转变（比如你毕业了，你结束了这条道路）而对这种既定的生活方式感到迷失方向时，身份危机就可能发生，这把我们推向了身份危机的下一阶段，并最终促成新身份的形成——所以身份扩散，这是下一个阶段，当个人
thought about it. You know, if we're using the university or the graduation example, if you've been studying your whole life from when you were like three years old to 21 or whenever we might graduate uni, we have this identity of ourselves as a student that's never really been tested. It's inherited and it feels normal. But an identity crisis might occur for individuals when we begin to grow disorientated with this established way of life due to some reason or some large shift like you graduate you're finished with this path and this pushes us into the next stage of an identity crisis and ultimately the formation of a new identity so identity diffusion this is the next stage and this occurs when an individual we neither kind of explore or commit to an
既不探索也不承诺某个身份时，就会发生这种情况。根据詹姆斯的说法，这是一种奇怪的过渡阶段，因为个人在某些时候将不得不面对他们的不确定性。在你能够进入延缓状态（在那里你调查你的信仰）之前，你有点被卡住了，有点瘫痪了。这位心理学家有一种理论，认为在你生命中的这个阶段，当你正走向探索新身份时，你有两个选择。要么你可以积极地向内看，你可以积极地，你知道的，去滋养你的热情并深入思考你是谁，要么你可能会陷入真正的停滞和抑郁状态，有时甚至陷入存在主义危机（这本身就是完全不同的一集内容），但只是一种
identity. It's kind of this weird transitory phase, according to James, as individuals will at some point have to face their uncertainty. And you kind of just stuck, you're kind of a bit paralyzed before you're able to move on to that moratorium status where you investigate your beliefs. And this psychologist, he kind of has this theory that at this point in your life, where you're moving into exploring a new identity, you have two choices. Either you can actively look inwards, you can actively, you know, kind of feed your passions and think deeply about who you are, or you can kind of slip into a state of real stagnation and depression, and sometimes even an existential crisis, which is an entirely different episode in itself, but a sense of just
“卡住”且你真的不知道自己是谁的感觉。但如果我们确实达到了延缓阶段，这就是你经历危机（即身份危机）的地方。你必须积极探索身份的可能性。你可能会对这种机会感到不知所措。但在成功克服这场危机后，你确实能够获得强烈的自我身份感。玛西亚认为，这些身份状态在本质上是循环往复的。因此，个人在贯穿他们一生的重大生活事件中，可能会经历
like stuck and you don't really know who you are. But if we do reach the moratorium phase, this is where you undergo a crisis, an identity crisis. And you actively have to explore possibilities for your identity. And you might be feeling really overwhelmed with that opportunity. But upon successfully kind of overcoming this crisis, you really are able to achieve a strong sense of self-identity. And Marcia, he believed that these identities, states were really cyclical in nature. So an individual might experience, you know, repeated deconstruction and creation of new identities throughout their lives associated with major life events. Whilst Erickson kind of talks about early adulthood is this really
身份的重复解构和新身份的创造，而埃里克森则认为成年初期是真正的一段
formative period, Marcia kind of completes his theory by stating that an identity crisis is likely to reoccur in adulthood. And that's what we call a midlife crisis. And it also implies that identity is not really concrete. And we might have to revise our identity a few times, not to kind of emerge as our true self, but to really create a sense of stability and happiness with where we are at the moment. Okay, if you're in this right now, this might seem really, really fucking stressful and confronting.
成型期，玛西亚通过指出身份危机很可能会在成年期再次发生，从而完善了他的理论。这就是我们所说的中年危机。这也意味着身份并非真正一成不变。我们可能需要多次修正我们的身份，不是为了展现出真正的自我，而是为了对我们目前的处境真正产生一种稳定感和幸福感。好吧，如果你现在正经历这一切，这可能会让你觉得非常、非常该死地压力山大且难以面对。
But I really want to approach this topic from a growth perspective. and a growth mindset. You know, whilst we're still going to acknowledge some of those stresses that may accompany an identity crisis, I ultimately think it's a really good thing. You know, questioning your sense of self might be stressful, but it's important in the long term, knowing who you are and adapting to changes and major life shifts. And coming out as a stronger version of yourself, maybe even as your true self, is going to allow you to grow as a person. So where to next? You know, you've undergone this incredible shift
但我真的希望从成长的角度和成长型思维来探讨这个话题。你知道，尽管我们仍然会承认伴随身份危机而来的一些压力，但我最终认为这是一件大好事。你知道，质疑自我认知可能会带来压力，但这对于长远来看了解你是谁、适应变化以及生活中的重大转变至关重要。以一个更强大的自己，甚至是以真正的自我破茧而出，将让你作为一个个体不断成长。那么接下来去哪？你知道，你经历了这种难以置信的转变
in identity. You're probably feeling really lost and detached from yourself. So what do you do? How can you get to a place of obtaining and recognizing your true self and having a concrete sense of identity? Okay, I asked you a few questions earlier on about what are your values. And we're going to return to this. And we're going to return to why this question is important. When our lives have been shaken up, it's really, really crucial to at least for some time detach from external validation and look inward. I know this sounds really wishy-washy and post-enlightenment, but let me explain by what I mean by this. So like Erickson kind of explained, at some stage of our lives, we're going to face a crisis of identity.
在身份认同上。你可能感到非常迷失，与自我脱节。那你该怎么办？你如何才能达到获得并认可真正自我、拥有具体身份认同的境界？好吧，我之前问过你几个关于你的价值观是什么的问题。我们将回到这个问题上来。我们将探讨为什么这个问题很重要。当我们的生活受到动摇时，至关重要的一点是，至少在一段时间内脱离外部认可，向内看。我知道这听起来很空洞、很后启蒙时代，但让我解释一下我这话的意思。所以，正如埃里克森所解释的那样，在我们人生的某个阶段，我们将面临身份危机。
And we can either move through it or, as James Marcia said, we can remember. remain distracted and lost and enter into a period of stagnation and existential crisis. And the best way to move through this is to seriously take some time out and look within yourself and ask yourself some of those questions we asked ourselves before about who you are. Ask yourself these questions and answer them over time to kind of figure out where you're at. Figure out what you really represent. And some of those questions might be, what are the qualities and characteristics that really define you right now? Is it, you know, those external things like your appearance?
我们可以度过它，或者正如詹姆斯·玛西亚所说，我们可以记住。保持分心和迷茫，进入停滞期和存在主义危机。度过这一关的最佳方式是认真抽出一些时间审视内心，问自己一些我们之前问过的问题，关于你是谁。问自己这些问题，并随着时间推移去回答它们，从而弄清楚你的处境。弄清楚你真正代表什么。其中一些问题可能是：真正定义你现在的品质和特征是什么？是那些外在的东西，比如你的外表吗？
Or is it something deeper? Like, I'm a nice person. I'm a generous person. I'm an honest person. If you're experiencing a major life change, sit with that feeling of instability and think about how is this changing me right now? How am I different from before this happened? and how can we kind of cope with these new things that are occurring? And then your values.
还是更深层次的东西？比如，我是个好人。我是个慷慨的人。我是个诚实的人。如果你正在经历生活中的重大变革，去体会那种不稳定感，思考一下：这在现在是如何改变我的？与这件事发生之前相比，我有什么不同？我们又该如何应对这些正在发生的新事物？然后是你的价值观。
You know, what are your values? I ask you do I think about five of them, but maybe think even deeper. And think about it deep, like really think about it. Like seriously think about what are the values that make up who I am, write them down, put them up in your room, put them up somewhere that's important. So when you're going about your life and you're feeling like this crisis of like, I don't know who I am. I don't know what I stand for. You can be like, you know, I've done this work. I actually do know who I am. I do know what my beliefs are and they are X, Y, Z. It's also important to really sink deeply into your interests and your passions and your hobbies. Are you doing
你知道，你的价值观是什么？我让你想想其中的五个，但或许可以想得更深。去深刻地思考，真正地去想。认真想想，究竟是什么价值观构成了我，把它们写下来，贴在你的房间里，贴在显眼的地方。这样当你在生活中前行，觉得正经历这种危机——“我不知道我是谁，我不知道我支持什么”时，你可以对自己说，你知道的，我已经做过这些功课了。我其实知道我是谁。我确实知道我的信仰是什么，它们就是 X、Y、Z。同样重要的是，要深深沉浸于你的兴趣、激情和爱好之中。你是否在做
what you like to do? You are actually enjoying your life? That's a really big question. Are you actually enjoying your life? And if not, why aren't you doing it? what are the factors that are preventing you from doing it? Maybe it's because you have this conflicting social role. Maybe your job is taking away from the thing that you really want to do. And that is part of that crisis. Like I said, when your social roles begin to conflict. It's also important to really ground yourself in what helps me in these moments.
你喜欢做的事？你真的在享受生活吗？这是一个非常大的问题。你真的在享受生活吗？如果没有，你为什么不去做？是什么因素阻碍了你？也许是因为你有这种相互冲突的社会角色。也许你的工作夺走了你真正想做的事。这也是那种危机的一部分。就像我说的，当你的社会角色开始冲突时。同样重要的是，要真正立足于在这些时刻什么能帮助我。
What is going to help me through? What are the relationships? what are the things, what are the activities that are going to make me feel like me and going to make me feel like my true self? All of these questions are really, really fundamental to ask yourself at some point in your life. And I think it's a pretty empty life you'll lead if you don't, or like both of these psychologists we've talked about today have explained, you're probably going to end up in a state of pretty serious existential dread if you don't push through and do that hard work to identify what really makes you you. I think in times like this, we really can't
什么能帮我度过难关？是什么样的关系，是什么事情，是什么样的活动会让我觉得自己像自己，让我觉得这就是真实的自我？在人生的某个阶段，问自己所有这些问题都是非常非常基础的。如果你不这么做，你将度过空虚的一生；正如我们今天谈到的这两位心理学家所解释的那样，如果你不迎难而上，去做那些艰难的工作来确定究竟是什么造就了真正的你，你最终可能会陷入相当严重的存在主义恐惧之中。我认为在这样的时刻，我们真的不能
understate the importance of friends and family. You know, these people, they might see the external version of you, but they do really tend to see you as you are. And if you ask them to be honest with you and if you say, like, who am I to you? What are my best qualities? Why do you like me? Why do you spend time with me? Why do you love me? I'm sure they'll have some. some pretty amazing answers. And it's a good way and it's a good start to kind of overcome this sense of crisis with who am I and asking yourself those questions. I think something else that I've done, which at times of crisis have really helped me, especially in my first years of uni where I was kind of undergoing this transition to adulthood and didn't really know who I was, was spending
低估朋友和家人的重要性。你知道，这些人看到的可能是你的外在版本，但他们确实往往能看到最真实的你。如果你请他们对你诚实，如果你问他们：在你们眼里我是谁？我最好的品质是什么？你们为什么喜欢我？你们为什么花时间陪我？你们为什么爱我？我确信他们会有一些。一些非常惊人的答案。这是克服“我是谁”这种危机感并向自己提出这些问题的一个好方法，也是一个好的开始。我认为我做过的另一件事，在危机时刻对我有很大帮助，特别是在我上大学的头几年，当时我正经历向成年期的过渡，并不太清楚自己是谁，那就是度过
time alone and in nature. There are so many points in the day where I will be like having a thought and I'll pick up my phone and that thought is gone. And I realize that I actually had an opportunity there to spend time with myself and to really sit back and think about, you know, what am I experiencing? Am I behaving in a way that's true to myself? Do I feel like myself at the moment? And I don't. But being able to spend time in solitude and spend time in nature and without distractions,
独处和贴近自然的时间。一天中有很多时候，我会产生一个想法，然后拿起手机，那个想法就消失了。我意识到，其实我本来有机会花时间陪伴自己，真正坐下来思考：我正在经历什么？我的行为是否忠于自我？此刻我觉得自己像自己吗？而我并没有。但能够享受独处时光，置身于大自然中，免受干扰，
it can be really healing and it can be like a really amazing antidote and kind of tonic for the soul. And if you're really struggling, if this is a really hard period for you where this lack of identity, this lack of sense of self is really starting to wear on you mentally, you can always seek professional help. I think that is such an important resource. Sometimes having an external opinion and an objective external opinion, not your friends and your family can be one of the best kind of shepherds. in a time like this where you're really seeking clarity about who you are and what you stand for.
这真的具有治愈作用，就像是对灵魂的一剂绝妙解药和滋补品。如果你真的在苦苦挣扎，如果这是一个对你而言十分艰难的时期，缺乏身份认同感、缺乏自我感开始在精神上真正折磨你，你随时可以寻求专业帮助。我认为这是一个非常重要的资源。有时，拥有一个外部观点以及客观的外部观点——而不是你的朋友和家人——可以成为最好的向导之一。在这样一个你真正渴望弄清自己是谁以及你坚守什么信念的时期。
I hope that you enjoyed this episode. We're kind of going to wrap up here. I've talked about what I wanted to talk about, and I hope that you've gained something from this. It was such an interesting episode to think about, and I really, you know, had to listen to my own advice and think about my values and think about what I love doing and what my interests and my hobbies and my passions are and why I might not be doing them, whether I really enjoy my life, like some pretty big existential questions associated with this topic. But like I said, important nonetheless. So I hope that if you're listening to this and you're undergoing and identity crisis, you take away two important things. Firstly, this is so normal. This is so natural.
希望你喜欢这一期节目。我们差不多要在这里收尾了。我已经讲了我想讲的内容，希望你从中有所收获。思考这个话题是一段非常有趣的经历，而且我真的，你知道，必须听取我自己的建议，思考我的价值观，想想我热爱什么、我的兴趣、爱好和激情是什么，以及我为什么可能没有去做它们，我是否真正享受生活——诸如此类与这个话题相关的相当重大的存在主义问题。但就像我说的，它们同样重要。所以我希望，如果你正在收听节目且正经历身份危机，你能从中汲取两件重要的事。首先，这太正常了。这是再自然不过的事了。
As you grow up and you enter adulthood and you have to figure out who you are and explore your individuality, it makes sense that this is something you're going to have to overcome. And secondly, like, there is a way through this. You're going to emerge as a better, brighter, true version of yourself if you do that work. And you sit with your feelings and you sit with your thoughts and you sit with your identity and examine all kind of elements and facets of it and ask yourself, like, am I really embodying who I truly believe I am? So thank you so much for listening. I hope you learned something. And as always, if you feel called to do so, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Spotify or Apple Podcasts or wherever you're listening right now.
随着你长大并步入成年，你必须弄清楚自己是谁并探索个性，那么你需要克服这一点就合情合理了。其次，总有办法度过难关。如果你付出了努力，去体味你的感受，正视你的思想，审视你的身份并检查其中的各种元素和面向，问自己诸如“我是否真的体现了我真正相信的自我”之类的问题，你就会以一个更好、更闪耀、更真实的自己破茧而出。非常感谢你的收听。希望你有所收获。一如既往，如果你愿意的话，请随时在 Spotify、Apple Podcasts 或你目前收听节目的任何地方留下五星好评。
Also a little plug, we now have paid subscriptions. You may have seen there are some episodes that have a little lock on them that you can't access. This is because they are for my amazing paid subscribers. And if you would like to be one, it's super easy. There's a link in the description of this podcast. It really helps this podcast grow. It allows me to kind of spend more time making episodes and be more serious about this little hobby that I have
顺便插播一个小广告，我们现在有了付费订阅。你可能已经看到有些剧集带有一个小锁，你无法访问。这是因为它们是留给我那些了不起的付费订阅者的。如果你想成为其中一员，超级简单。本播客的简介里有一个链接。这真的对本播客的成长很有帮助，它让我能够花更多时间制作节目，并更加认真对待我这个小爱好
and this mission that I have to kind of share more with people about the way that psychology really impacts our lives, not just in a clinical mental illness kind of setting, but in every facet. And thank you so much for listening and supporting the podcast. I will see you next week. We're going to be discussing codependency. On The Look Back at it podcast.
以及我的使命，即向人们分享更多关于心理学如何真正影响我们生活的知识，不仅仅是在临床精神疾病的背景下，而是在方方面面。非常感谢您的收听和对本播客的支持。我们下周见。我们将讨论共同依赖症。欢迎收听《回首过往》播客。
In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
1979年，那对我来说是个重要时刻。84年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games.
84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首过往》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯为您带来的《艰难一课》。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着铠甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去使用它。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mianini.
在 AHA 广播应用、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难一课》。2023年，“钻石单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这段怀孕经历似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，甚至更多。我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·米安尼尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我的天哪，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《被困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《被困之爱》播客。这是一个 IHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。